oh wow um yeah welcome to this video it
is requested this game and then did
something else which was irritating
lemme go for this this long oh that's in
fact uncommon can I go h6 or is this a
bad idea with the capture coming yeah
that's not really not really working ok
so do i play g5 here directly trying to
exploit his his weird piece
configuration or do I wait with this
it's um it's tempting trying to play
against the misplaced pieces if he goes
95 this may be Queen d5 attacking the
knight and threatening Bishop takes age
three ok so he wants to wants to play
95g 495 hmm
very funny situation is this possible g
495 Queen Queen deform the ton of pieces
hanging now this is this is just just
very very crazy and i'm tempted to to do
that and now queen deform there's lots
of stuff hanging now night the both
nights the bishop in a way I don't know
don't know Bishop f17 t8 sure first
impression is that I should get lots of
lots of material him jack okay that's
easy at least of course my king is is
running around eh yeah but i can check
if I hear right when F was also not bad
to take but with a check cookie okay so
I'm a piece up rear right for nothing in
particular d for coming
can I win wouldn't have seven here maybe
maybe oh d 4
yeah let's just let's just trade this d
4 24 maybe maybe the easiest not Sancho
okay the Queen can come to f5 and all
night f4 and you might have rookie 196
but okay 96 I'm going to see eight yeah
maybe i can i can do something on my own
here with g3 um yeah but I can take it
really takes takes Queen d7 check in CN
and check
it's really a lots of material that's
it's a look where I whole look and now
to jam mm-hmm King king and queen I in
the the D file that's not so nice I
should probably return some material or
can I go can I go somewhere I can I can
always go to see aid night h5 now I can
always go to see eight now it's still a
bit still a bit tricky this position
of course the rook is quite nice to have
but
it's not easy
yeah time morning green here you can
give the check and double on the D file
I can move the bishop though okay i only
have 50 seconds
check Queen moves are played bishop yeah
Bishop g7 s night e seven but I can
certainly do anything else
all rights very dangerous tween age 70
that's very very difficult don't know
where my where my knight should go
probably nowhere check
always somewhat frustrating I mean just
just material up for basically nothing
then you feel for fall victim to the
last last hope counterplay which really
shouldn't work check check check check
alright so draw now check that he will
certainly avoid it to win on time check
check I know it's not a row now it's not
a drum it probably it wasn't any way
sorry every second time yeah of course
this is a bit frustrating after such a
nonsensical opening by white with black
just being a pisa but the defensive set
up was probably not very good not very
reliable I wonder how to how to improve
it yeah this is probably still okay and
maybe you can okay what what can you say
it is just winning I just I probably
should avoid this move now King c7 and
that's a champ that's really that this
is decisive EF Andy five and that stats
over Bishop c5 route dat black gets even
more active here ah very very
frustrating I mean check okay well this
is of course also win but you can easily
stumble the compass on minus 5 and so on
but jam it's it's still possible to to
go wrong
why didn't I go to see seven here this
is how to explain just better minus
seven also minus six check even here
black is totally winning with Luke edge
aid it was very difficult to lose this
but I managed I overlooked Luke age
eight simply I thought the night has no
protection but with 30 seconds against
one minute forty eight sides of course
not so easy Luke age eight Queenie 4 p-8
and that's it no no one no nothing yeah
of course um I must I should directly
repaint this this with King c7 this is I
didn't see five as I saw King c7 of
course but I didn't look at if I've I
was just thinking okay I take on f6 and
this wasn't so clear to me can continue
here but ok also this is also my king is
save him ja very difficult to lose the
game but I managed those things
sometimes thanks for watching